hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zur neuen folge
minecraft heute
so wie immer meine lieben freunde wenn
ihr facts hat dann sind mir die bitte
per mail an kraft die man dort komme
richtig cool effect am start up einfach
mal kräftig den betreff schreiben und
dann kommen kräfte gmail.com senden und
ich würde mich freuen wenn wir zum ende
dran bleibt weil mir heute prominente
leute fakten zugesendet
naja egal bis
jetzt viel spaß so guckt jetzt einfach
mal so freunde der erste effekt wurde
mir zugesendet von eric und zwar meint
er ich solle mir einfach mal anrufen
wollen deswegen habe ich mir einen
geholt und hat den hingelegt und da kann
ich als beispielsweise einfach mal mein
komplettes eisenerz reinpacken und einen
lover und jetzt seht ihr schon okay der
lava einmal wird er dadurch leer weil er
man kann ja ein lover einmal als
heizmittel benutzen wie das denke ich
jeder kennt so wie kohle oder holz
stämme oder sticks oder setzlinge oder
irgendwie sowas in der richtung einfach
irgendwas als brennmittel und dann
bekomme ich hier das eisen raus das soll
allerdings heute nicht das thema sein
und zwar nicht jetzt erstmal die ganzen
sachen raus und zwar wenn ich einen
eimer reintun dann packte einen nassen
schwamm rein dann wird dieser klassisch
war ihr seht schon das immer noch die
power drin von dem lager einmal von
vorhin der wir zu einem trockenen
schwamm und was mich wundert hier in den
eimer kommt wasser rein und das wird zu
einem wassereimer ich denke ihr euch
vielleicht suchen ja okay dass wir einen
normalen schwamm rauskriegen ist ja klar
und das gesagt was wahr ist ist ja auch
klar weil der schwamm beta das wasser
muss ja irgendwo hin allerdings kann man
sich das mal überlegt und zwar man
erhitzt diesen diesen nassen schwamm
dann erhitzt denen und wenn man wasser
erhitzt so dass das wasser verschwindet
dann sieht das wasser und
dementsprechend löste sich in luft auf
der aggregatzustand ändert sich und das
wasser ist wächst das was bei diesem
ofen hier passiert ist quasi einfach nur
dass der schwamm ausgewogen wird in den
leeren eimer und nicht erhitzt deswegen
finde ich man sollte das lieber
irgendwie den wasser das wasser
dingsbums irgendwie wegpacken irgendwie
kann man hier zum beispiel rock ich bin
im creative sag das jetzt mal ganz kurz
einfach so und zwar wenig besser wenn
man ganz einfach einen nassen schwamm
ins inventar legen müsste mit einem
leeren eimer und dann würde an ihren
ganz normalen
bekommen und nicht mit offen dass man im
ofen ist natürlich cool und witzig
gemacht und so aber ich weiß nicht was
macht irgendwie keinen sinn dass man
einen nassen schwamm erhitzt und dann
wasser da rauskommen fall eigentlich
wird das dann nur zu wasserdampf und ja
das perfekt nummer eins nächste wurde
mir zugesendet von sandro und zwar
schreibt sandro hey luca wenn man im
survival mode ndb huhn mit 64 weizen
fitted wird jetzt erwachsen also ich
muss hier erstmal ein baby münchen und
jetzt schon ich habe hier 64 weizen
können dafür gehe ich mal ganz kurz in
den games 0 und klicke der so lange
drauf bis zu 64 mal verballert hallo
freunde der final countdown hier und
jetzt seht ihr schon da sind die ganze
zeit so grüne teile darüber gewesen ich
habe 64 weizen dann verbraucht jetzt
müssen wir ein kleines momentchen warten
und da seht ihr schon jetzt direkt wo
ich gegen gelaufen bin ist dieses
münchen erwachsen geworden wir können
das ganze auch selber ausprobieren falls
ich jetzt eventuell denkt dass es daran
liegt dass tasci ein bisschen
weggeschoben geschubst habe und zwar
eigentlich ist es ja so was denke ich
auch nicht viele wissen ein hühnchen
braucht genau 20 minuten bis es ein
erwachsenes männchen wird also das ist
so wie bei uns quasi mit 18 jahren dass
man ja laut gesetz und ermöglichen
norman ist man mit 18 jahren
ausgewachsen das heißt diese 18 jahre
bei menschen dauern bei ihnen einfach 20
minuten in minecraft und das kann man
beschleunigen den man ihm einfach so
viele weisen kann da gibt wie man hat
bei 64 stück muss man danach noch fünf
bis zehn sekunden warten und das tun wir
erwachsen das hat er so wie besondere
rausgefunden dann kann dich anrufe für
diesen coolen und mit diesem hühnchen
wagen gegen weltweite nummer drei dritte
wurde mir zugesendet von paul
pauli vfl
ii vfl wahrscheinlich weil das irgendwie
dann fußballclub oder
kraft ich habe einen coolen fake bin ich
uns weiß kann auch regnen wenn man die
wolken ausstellt dahinten wind ein paar
wolken am start ich kann jetzt einfach
die einstellungen gehen in die
grafikeinstellungen details und kann
hier die cloud auf aufstellen und dann
sind die keine klotz und wenn ich jetzt
mal top down foul eingebe seht ihr schon
es fängt hier an zu schneien weil ich in
einem kleinen schnee billionen wenn ich
allerdings mal hierhin fliege hier fängt
beispielsweise jetzt gerade an zu regnen
wo kommt diese regen her das war eine
sache da hab ich bei twitter gefragt ob
es möglich ist dass man einstellt dass
es die ganze zeit schneit und das wäre
nämlich echt ganz cool dass man sagen
tolles ruckelt das hier sogar meinen pc
s on the witches und zwar wäre das
eigentlich ganz cool wenn man sagen
könnte okay ich die in die einstellungen
grafikeinstellungen detailed und mach
hier die clouds einfach aus und dann
regnet es auch nicht mehr allerdings
habt ihr gesehen als ich habe zehn
niederschlag eben umgestellt dass es
dann trotzdem noch weiter regnet das
denke ich wäre eine ganz coole sache
wenn minecraft hinzufügen würde ja wenn
man die cloud aus stellt dann ist
außerdem auch der regen für immer aus
weil viele können das einfach nicht
managen mit dem computer irgendwie dass
man da die ganze zeit mit regen auch
wenn regen ist und so das leck bei denen
extrem und ich finde das wäre ganz coole
neuerung wenn man wenn man sagen würde
auch wenn man die wolken aus stellt dann
kamen außerdem bitten wird es nie wieder
regnen weil die wolken halt nicht da
sind und hier regnet halt trotzdem wenn
man weiß nicht wo der regen her kommt
man weiß ja der regen kommt von über den
wolken und realistischer sein sollte
müsste der regen auch ausgehen wenn die
wolken ausgegangen ausgestellt sind
blabla und dann kann dich paul dass du
sowas herausgefunden wo ihr mit ideen
die ich jung war fühlen uns schriftlich
du im würfel herstellt minecraft
megawatt man kriegt drei türen in der
altmark auf das ist ihm aufgefallen als
wir minecraft fries aufgenommen haben in
einer der letzten folgen und zwar meinte
ich erhöhe man kriegt drei türen raus
dann auch soja als mir auch letztes
aufgefallen höhe controller kann mir
vorstellen dass folglich sind wir das
mal zu hatte mir zugesendet einfach in
die kommentare geschrieben und zwar
jetzt hier schon ändert 1.8 wurde
hinzugefügt dass man bei dieser tour
konstruktion drei türen rausbekommt in
diesem weihnachtszeit steigt wenn ja
diese fichtenholz türen einfach aus wie
solche wie patrick
auf jeden fall drei türen rausbekommen
im creative habe ich jetzt halt ich
unendlich aber ihr seht im inventar drei
stück das geht nicht nur dabei sondern
auch wenn ich mir beispielsweise einfach
mal birkenholz nehmen und daraus eine
tür mache seht ihr da bekomme ich auch
draußen nicht auch mal so richtig coole
hinsetzen und da seht ihr schon ich habe
immer einfach drei türen hier raus ich
verstehe nicht was ist bringt weil diese
diese ich weiß nicht dass das ist doch
viel zu viel bei leitern in ordnung wenn
man davor relativ viel sticks verwendet
und für sticks verein stick braucht man
auch zwei wurden place aber bei türen
will ich das einfach nie hinzufügen dass
man da drei stück raus bekommt also ich
weiß echt nicht was das bringt ich habe
hier drei stück im inventar von den
beiden sorten ich habe keine ahnung was
das soll was das für einen sinn hat dass
das so hinzugefügt wurde aber es ist nun
mal einfach so und mit zugewinnen von
sturm war der sänger nichts sagen
genommen ihr habt wieder ein bild
eingeblendet das habe ich in letzter
zeit öfter gemacht hat wenn ihr mehr
coole bilder zu senden oder irgendwas
cooles aus einem buch über minecraft
oder eine optische täuschung dass ich
irgendwas haben wir nicht darauf gerne
mal bilder an das habe ich auch hier
gemacht bei dem fact damit zugesandt
wurde von martin und zwar schreibt der
martin hack und crafter video auf dem
bild sehen kann sind die gelbe wolle
oben heller oder dunkler je nachdem wie
die us boys und unten dunkler oder
heller beachtet wurde die gelbe wolle
hinbauen muss und dann seht ihr ja die
ganze zeit schon das bild eingeblendet
das ist eine sehr coole optische
täuschungen hier in minecraft
nachgestellt wurde ich weiß nicht da
kann ich nicht viel zu sagen dass es
halt einfach so eine optische täuschung
ist ist auf jeden fall die gleiche gelbe
wolle ihr seht nur unten ist die wolle
auf die weißen dinge drauf gezeichnet
deswegen wird die wolle anders weil sie
zwischen den grünen den grünen linien
ist und oben links ist sie auf die
grünen linien gezeichnet und deswegen
wirkt sie heller weil sie zwischen den
weißen linien zu sehen ist ich habe ja
schon mal sowas gemacht wo ich euch zehn
optische illusionen vorgestellt habe und
einfach eine runde reiten siegen
hintergrund gepackt habe allerdings habe
ich letztens bei einem anderen coolen
deutschen minecraft kanal ein richtig
cooles video entdecken zwar erzählt er
da über fünf optische illusionen die in
minecraft nachgebaut wurden bzw in
minecraft erstellt wurden die sind zwar
nicht von ihm erstellt worden sondern
ganz normale minecraft wo um von ihnen
amerikaner oder von dem engländer wollt
ihr allerdings mal dass darüber auch
bericht ich werde natürlich alle credits
geben dass jeder auch die leute den
richtigen artikel sehen würde wenn ihr
das wollt dann schreibt sie meine
kommentare und zeigt es mir mit einer
bewertung ob besonnen minecraft fünf
optische illusionen video haben wollte
und dann würde ich sagen war es das auch
schon für diese folge der minecraft
hacks ich hoffe euch hat es mal wieder
gefallen
eigentlich gar nicht zu sagen